Little one, you're on stage. How you
doing? Hello. Can you hear me? I can
barely hear you, man. You're gonna have
to speak up just a little bit. No, I'm
just sleepy. Okay. What is the argument?
You got to wake up. No, this is going to
wake you up. The argument is Islam is
false. Okay, cool. So, he said he said
cool. So, that's basically allowed to
Islam is false. You ready to repeat
after me? Nice to meet you. Shu. Okay.
What? Why is it false? Oh, good
question. Okay. Good question. Okay.
Yeah, that's that's all right. All
right, next step. The reason why what is
the title of the life? If there's a
problem with my device that I can see.
Yeah. So, the title says, "Will the
Quran escape this dilemma?" Okay. So,
it's about the dilemma thing. Okay. Mhm.
You've heard of it? Yeah. Yeah.
Everyone's heard of it now, Avery. Okay.
So, what do you think of it? What do you
think of it? What do you think of it? I
don't really know anything about it. Oh,
you came to the right place. Yeah. Yeah,
that's okay. So, so it goes like this.
The Quran all over the place
explicitly confirms the truthfulness and
the authority of the previous
scriptures, the Torah, the Psalms, the
Gospels, and what is in the possession
of the Jews and Christians. It says that
what they have is true. It's good. They
should judge on by it. They got to stand
on it. They have to recite it correctly.
And they can even find Muhammad written
in there. Okay. What? What? What's the
last part? They can find Muhammad in
their scriptures. Okay. So, okay. So,
our scriptures are true. We have them.
Muhammad, we can find Muhammad mentioned
in them there somewhere. And we have
nothing to stand on unless we stand on
our scriptures. If we don't judge by our
scriptures, then we're disobeying our
law and we can't pick and choose. We got
to believe in it all. Right? The problem
is is that since the Quran confirms them
and says they're true and all these
things, it also at the same time
contradicts what they say. Like for
example, if I were to go into the
Torah and and I'd read that God is our
father. When I read Moses talking about
God, he says that God is our father who
created us. When I read the Injeal, the
gospel, I see that Jesus died for my
sins and rose again on the third day.
And the Quran says no, no, no, to all of
this. Right? So the Quran contradicts
the same scriptures that it says are
true. So since it confirms the the these
scriptures, if these scriptures are
true, then the Quran is false because it
contradicts these true scriptures. If
these scriptures are corrupted and false
somehow, then the Quran is still false
because it's saying that false books are
true. And that's the dilemma.
M Yeshua
uh uh isn't it referring to the
scriptures that was given to Moses and
Jesus? Nope. And not what you have
today? Nope. Cuz it says again that was
the the very first thing that I said my
brother is that the Quran says that they
have it in their possession. It's
confirming what we have. Okay. What is
the Quran verse that say this? Chapter 4
verse 47 is one of them. There's a lot.
Yeah, but chapter 4:41 just to start off
of the gospel just by what Allah has
revealed in it and those would chapter
chapter 45 that's 547 that's a good one
too that's one of my favorites but 447
547 works too but 447 is what I was
talking about okay let me look at uh oh
you were given the book believe in what
has revealed to you okay and confirming
what away from confirming what
confirming your own scripture it's
interesting saying as far as I can tell
that is the main argument given to the
people of the book for why we should
believe in Muhammad and the Quran. The
main reason the Quran gives us for
believing in Muhammad and the Quran is
that the Quran and Muhammad affirm
affirm our scriptures. It refers to the
Quran by the way. What? Yeah. It says it
says that we are supposed to believe the
Quran. Yeah. Because it confirms the
scriptures we have already. That's kind
of that's kind of the issue we have.
That's kind of the issue we have. The
Quran says, the Quran says, "Hey,
believe in the Quran. Why should we
believe in the Quran? Why should we
believe this?" Well, the Quran affirms
your book. Since the Quran affirms your
book, what you have, therefore, you
should return the favor and believe in
the Quran as well. But then we hear from
Muslims and they say, "No, the Quran
doesn't affirm your book. It affirms
some original that you don't have." And
so, okay, so it's not affirming what we
have, but the Quran says it's affirming
what we have, and that that's the reason
we're supposed to believe in it. So,
Muslims are basically telling us that
the Quran is lying about what it's uh
about its main argument for us. Okay.
When it says confirming your confirming
your own scriptures. Uhhuh. I think it's
it's referring u to the Torah and indeed
because it's talking here about the
people of the book. Yes. So, correct.
Wait, let me read you. So, your own your
own scriptures is actually referring to
their original original scriptures. It
says what's with them right now. What is
with you?
Means right now. Present tense. Yeah.
They had it already. He just said you're
just said you're right. Congratulations.
You got the Islamic dilemma. Yeah. Okay.
I just um don't know really much about
this dilemma, but we can That's okay.
That's That's why you're here. That's
very honest. Yeah. That's why you're
here. You're in like David said, you're
in you're in the right place. You're in
the right place. Yeah. And uh let me
just let me uh so you've got this live
stream. You've got some uh you got some
uh some verses to look up. Uh check out
three. Negative, by the way. Oh, I'm
just saying I'm I'll give you give you a
quick rundown of some verses to go
through because we definitely don't have
time to go through all of them. You're
not telling me to go out and look at
them by myself. No, I'm I'm saying look
these up on your own. We don't want to
we don't want to like catch you off
guard with anything. It's good to just
go through these passages and think
about what they mean. But surah 3 3-4 uh
that says that Allah revealed the Torah
and the gospel. So that's the
inspiration.
Surah 3:es 3 to 4. 3 to 4. Yeah. Surah
3:es 3 to 4. Uh surah 7 verse 157 says
that Jews and Christians still have the
Torah in the Gospel that they're uh
still reading it and so on. This is
where we're told we can find Muhammad 34
says it sends down the criterion which
is the Quran. So it's saying to use the
Quran as a criterion between them. It
never says that it doesn't. Yeah. The
Torah the Torah the Torah is also the
Torah is also the the criteria not
to say the what does the mean verse
three the verse before it
I'm talking about three four. Yeah.
Four. And then is the Quran. Yeah. And
and then he and what does it mean? Yeah.
Alan. That's a good question. Ab says
Alan can be any book from Allah.
Exactly.
Yeah. Any book. He said he says a
collective name for all the books of
Allah. It can be referring to the Injil.
It could be referring to the Torah. He
said it can refer to any of the books,
not just the Quran. That's what this guy
who say no. This guy this guy knows
better than Iban Abbas. Uh oh. Do you
know Wait, do you know who I is? First
of all, yes, I know. Okay.
Who is INBZ? Just for the people
listening. Who is he? As far as I know,
Alan is only used to describe the Quran.
No, you're wrong. You're wrong. That's
what people think. That's what people
think. But your says, your taps says
it's I'm not talking about the Where is
in the Look, I I got I got you, brother.
Here's chapter 21:48. Look at this. It
says, "And verily we gave Musa and Harun
Aaron al Faran a criterion and a light
and a reminder, right, for the
righteous." So the criteria, the furan
was also given to Moses, which is the
Torah, right? Yeah. And keep, by the
way, keep going to verse 53 as well. 53,
same thing. Yep. So actually, Faran is
not just the Quran. That's what people
Sorry. Sorry. Sorry. I thought you were
in chapter 2. 253. Yeah. 253. Yeah.
You see, so is actually any book from
Allah. Okay, good point. But my what I'm
really saying
is
alan does actually mean the criterion.
So when you say uh 33 which says he sent
down upon you oh Muhammad the book in
the Jews confirming what was being
before you before it and he revealed the
Torah and the the gospel before before
as guidance for mankind. That's 34. And
he has sent down the criterion. So what
I mean by this uh what it could be any
look notice it the Quran's already
mentioned in verse three along with the
Torah and the gospel then the criterion.
Okay. And then the criterion is
mentioned. How you know it's not talking
about the zabor about what? The zabor
the song. The the song. No he's saying
where does it say? So you don't know the
name in Arabic. Zabor. Zabur is um you
know um the Psalms. You know Psalms.
Yeah. Psalms. The Psalms that was given
to David. You know that, right? Oh yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So So how do you know it's
not talking about the Psalms? Cuz the
Quran's already mentioned. So is the
Torah and Gospel. The book that's left
is the Psalms. Uh because it says, "Oh,
Muhammad." It's talking to Muhammad.
Wait. It Where is it? Where does it say
Muhammad? You're reading an English
translation. It doesn't say Muhammad.
Yeah. Where is Mia Muhammad? No, they
add this because uh following the
context. Yeah. No, that's not the
context. That's they misinterpret.
So the translation is lying. Correct.
Yeah. You're reading verse three. So
you're on verse four. Verse three is the
one where it says, "Oh Muhammad in the
translation." Yeah. Because it says, "We
are sent upon you." That's why it says,
"Oh." Verse four doesn't say.
Say is actually talking.
Yeah. Yeah. That's in the verse before.
No, no problem. No problem. But what God
lo saying is the next verse. He's saying
how do you know the next
verse? How do you know this isn't
referring to any of the other books of
Allah? And by the way, where do you get
the idea that thisan is to judge the
other books of Allah? Where do you get
that idea from? It just means there's a
criterion in general, not not between
Allah's books. Yeah. It's like when when
the when the when the Quran uh says that
uh the Torah was the criterion, that
obviously didn't mean the Torah is the
criterion over books that came before
the Torah and that it's judging them.
You end up with this like Russian doll
situation where this book's judging this
book is judging this book is judging
this book is judging this book. Like
where does it end? When a specific book
is uh is mentioned in the Quran to be as
corrupted or changed. No, where does it
say that? Yeah. The closest you get to a
saying a a book has been corrupted in
the Quran is uh 1590 to91 which says
that the the Quran was made into shreds.
Um but other than that Yeah. Where's it
where does it say that about the Torah
or the Gospel about what them being
corrupted? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. By the way,
matter of fact, give give us one word
saying that the Torah and the Gospel has
been corrupted. By the way, did did you
know that? Sorry. What was his name?
Muhammad. Oh, his name is um Oh, dot,
right? It was just a dot, right? No, no,
no. That's somebody else. This one's
little one. Little little one. Wait,
little one. Little one. Did you know
that what David just said that the Quran
speaks about one of Allah's books that
was shredded? Did you know that? No.
It's funny because you know David
mentioned that in his video that the
Muslim wouldn't know that because most
Muslims don't know that. But did you
know that? Did you know that though that
there's a book Oh, sorry. You just you
didn't know. Sorry. But there is a book
there is a book in chap in chapter 15.
Go to chapter 15 verses 90 to 91. And
you're going to be surprised what book
was shredded. What book was shredded?
You're going to be very surprised. It
wasn't the Injil. It wasn't the Torah.
There's a book that was shredded. Do you
know you know what it means? Shredded.
It's it's a it's a it's a it's a
difficult Arabic word. You know the
word. Do you know what means? It's like
a Quranic word. It's obvious that you do
you not read your Quran? I don't think
he knows the Quran because if someone
read the Quran, they would already know
that word. Okay, let me see.
Number 91. So basically, if you're going
to talk about any book that the Quran
talks about is being corrupted, we're
saying that you'd think that the Quran
is because it was torn into shreds.
Yeah. Okay. Yeah. What what is this
word? It's situation rejecting others.
Accept parts of the Quran. Yeah.
Oh, part. Yeah. Yeah.
Accepting like basically means like, you
know, something that was that was
something that was shredded, you know,
torn torn into pieces. You know, if you
get a page, you tear it into piece and
again into piece and tearing it to
pieces. Wait, let me check it. Okay. Oh,
I thought you didn't I thought you
didn't go to by the commentaries, but
when we quoted Yeah, you didn't like it.
Now you want to go to the commentaries.
Oh, that's interesting. Okay. You have
to be consistent. If you want to go to
the you have to accept the for
everything and that says and that says
the is every book from
Allah to Yeah. Yes. Yes. I I admit that.
I just didn't know. You admit? Okay,
that's that's good. So what do you think
about this verse that says the Quran's
corrupted
says which parts so that means the
translation the the translation say who
now accept parts of the Quran says uh I
think it's referring to the people who
accept parts of the Quran and reject the
others like for example like for example
uh like what you want us to do with
Torah and the Injil like kind of like
that Like you say parts of it are true.
You say parts of the Injil are true and
the other parts aren't true. Kind of
like what you do with the Yeah.
Something like accepting. Thank you. So
people are condemning the Quran putting
into shredding in the Quran into parts.
But that's what you want us to do with
the Injil in the Torah. It's not saying
shing or whatever that means. It says
accepting parts of the Quran. Right.
Exactly. Exactly. But if you accept
parts that mean you reject reject the
other parts. So you're tearing it into
shreds. Yeah. But but yes, but you are
not corrupting it. Yeah, but exactly.
But if if they don't accept, we want you
to imagine if that verse came and said
the Torah and the Injil are shredded.
What would Muslims do with that verse?
That's not the argument. I know, but I'm
asking you, what would happen if there
was a verse in the Quran that says the
Torah and the Gospels are are are in
parts shredded? What would you what
would you make? Is it is there a verse
that say this? No, there isn't.
Okay, there is I'm asking you if if
there is a verse that said the Torah and
the Gospel are shredded in parts. What
would you what would Muslims say? My
point is Well, you're not answering the
question. Doesn't even Yes. Yes. The
verse doesn't even say the Quran is shed
in parts. It it says they make it into
parts. Yeah. So, accept parts of the
Quran and reject the other. Yeah. Yeah.
That's your interpretation of what it
means. But I'll accept that. I'm asking
you if there was a verse in the Quran
that said they accept parts and reject
parts of the Torah and the Gospel, what
would Muslims make of that verse? That
verse does already exist. Where is it?
Okay, so great. So wait a minute. So it
exists for the Torah in the exist for
the Quran. So where does it say the
Torah is corrupted or the angel is
corrupted? I will bring the verse. Okay.
I just the first the verse that say
accepting parts of the scriptures is
actually does do exist. Okay. Excellent.
We we love that. It's referring to the
Torah when the uh Wait, what was the
verse again? Yeah, we we know. You're
right. You're right. You're right. There
is I I want you to go to that verse to
tell us what God what your Allah will
think if we did that with the Torah and
the Gospel. Okay. Wait. Okay. Am I
wasting your time or something? No. No,
you're not. No, no, you're not. You're
actually It's actually a very good
discussion. You just sound tired. That's
all. You sound like You sound like
you're Do you want help? I'm okay. I'm
okay. We can help you out if you want.
It's 2 285. Yes. 285. Very good. You
want do you want to read it? Okay. Let
me read it. Okay. So, just be clear. You
think this verse is saying here you are.
Here you are. Yellow. Um, do you want me
to read it? Go ahead. You can read it
and then tell us. Here you are killing
each other and Yes. expelling some
people from their homes, hiding one
another in sin and aggression. And when
those expelled come to you as captives,
you still run them. expelling them was
unlawful for you. Do you believe in some
of the scripture and reject the rest? Is
there any reward for those who do among
you other than disgrace in this world
life and being subjected into harshest
punishment on the day of judgment? For
Allah is never unaware of what you do.
Okay. Okay. So, uh which which book is
this talking about being disbelieving
and believing in parts? It's probably
the the Torah. Correct. Very good. So
what what is what is our punishment if
we have the Torah and we only believe in
one part and not the other?
Is your answer? Okay. Sorry. Okay. So
what's the answer? Sorry. But according
to Yes.
So also for the people listening, what's
the answer also for them? Answer of
what? So if we take the Torah and we
only believe in parts of it and reject
the other parts, what's the punishment
for that according to this verse that
you quoted?
Yeah. The most powerful the the the
severest punishment, right? Yeah.
Severest punishment. So, how can it be
corrupted? So, how can it be corrupted?
I don't really understand the question.
So, look, your your Quran is saying that
you're not to take parts of the Torah.
You're not to take parts of the Torah
and reject the other parts. In other
words, you're supposed to take all of
it, right? Otherwise, otherwise you get
you get there is punishment. So, yeah,
you agree that's what it's saying? No,
but the context is very important by the
way. Okay. What's the context?
Okay. Now you want to go back to now you
want to get to I mean the commentaries
don't don't really change the argument
but um is very important identity.
Dude dude we know exactly what the
commentaries say and this is in Ibn
Cathir as well. He says that you
basically had three Jewish tribes and
two Arab tribes. And you had two Jewish
tribes aligned with one Arab tribe and
another Jewish tribe aligned with a
different with the other Arab tribe. And
that when the Arab tribes would fight,
you would have Jews fighting on both
sides. And so they would be killing
their own people uh because they're
fighting on both sides of this battle.
And then they would take captives and
then they have to ransom captives and so
on. And it's saying you're not supposed
to be doing this. You're not supposed to
be fighting against your own people. But
then once he says it, once he points
out, he says, "So you're obeying parts
of the Torah, ransoming ransoming
captives. That's part of it. You're
you're doing that correctly, but you're
you're you're fighting and expelling
your fellow Jews, which you are told not
to do that. So you're violating the
Torah." And then what's the criticism?
He doesn't just say, "Hey, you're doing
things wrong." He says, "Do you believe
in parts and reject other parts?" If you
do that, if you do what? If you believe
in if you only believe in parts of your
book and you reject other parts, he says
he'll send you to hell. What's this
mean? Because it's the opposite of what
Muslims tell us. Muslims tell us, "Yes,
your book's been corrupted, so only
parts are reliable and other parts you
have to ignore." But that's exactly what
Allah says he will send people to hell
for in 285. And so tying this all
together um we we we we talked about
1590 to91 which just says that uh people
made the Quran people made the Quran
into parts or shreds. They shredded the
Quran. And we say okay what does that
mean? Because that's the harshest
language the Quran uses of any book.
Right? The harshest language in the
Quran used about any book is not about
the Bible. It's used about the Quran. It
says the Quran was shredded. DOC pointed
out that if it had said if it had said
the Torah was shredded, Muslims would
point to that and say, "You see, the
Quran says the Torah was shredded."
Well, it doesn't say that about the
Torah. Doesn't say that about the
Gospel. Doesn't say that about the
Psalms. It says it about the Quran
itself. So, what happens when Muslims
are told, "Hey, the harshest language
you have about any book in the Quran is
what the Quran says about the Quran."
What do you do with that? And you say,
"Oh, what it means to say the Quran was
shredded or made into parts. It just
means it just means that people were
only believing in parts and not
believing in other parts." We say,
"Okay, fine." But if that's what the
Quran is condemning people for, only
believing in parts and not believing in
other parts, he doesn't just say that
about the Quran. He says that about the
Torah as well. He says, "If you just
believe in parts and don't believe in
other parts, you're going to hell." But
here, Muslims say, "Oh, yeah, yeah, but
but yeah, that's true. But your book's
been corrupted. Oh well, okay, fine. In
surah 15, when it says they broke the
the Quran, I mean the when they broke
the Quran into parts, then that would
mean the Quran's been corrupted uh as
well. So, in other words, you can't just
you can't just pick and choose here. The
Quran very clearly condemns anyone in
Surah 2:85 who would only believe in
parts of the Torah and not in other
parts. And it's the exact opposite of
what almost every Muslim will ever
encounter tells us. Almost every Muslim,
there are exceptions, but almost every
Muslim we ever run into says, "Yeah,
you're just supposed to believe in parts
of the Torah, not in other parts because
it's been corrupted." And that's exactly
what Allah says he'll send people to
hell for. So, in other words, the entire
Muslim ummah is telling us to do
something that Allah says he'll send us
to hell for. And it actually sounds like
we're dealing with uh close to two
billion apostates. Okay, good point. But
the thing is uh he is uh when it says
accepting parts of the Torah and
rejecting the rest uh I think it's
referring to the action they did action
they did by like killing each other and
expelling people from their homes and
all these things are condemned in your
uh in your Hebrew Bible which I guess is
called the Torah. I don't know. So we
believe that the book you have right now
can contain some truth like for for
example as I said uh condemning the
these actions. So hang on hang on just
to be just to be clear are you saying
our book contains some truths but some
non-truths and therefore we should only
believe in parts of our book. Is that
what you're telling us? Cuz I literally
just said that Muslims tell us the exact
opposite of what Allah says and 5
seconds later you tell us the exact
opposite of what Allah says. We don't
say that we should believe in parts of
the book and reject the rest just
because there are some falsehood in it.
We use the Quran as a judge to see which
is true and which is false. Oh, so so so
parts parts of the Torah are true and
parts of the Torah are false and we
should reject the parts that are false
and only believe in the parts that are
true. Right. Yeah. Because it's okay.
You just said Yeah. Allah says if you
only believe in parts and you don't
believe in all of it, he'll send you
he'll send us to hell. And and then I I
when I said that, I said, "And Muslims
say the opposite, and they tell us to do
exactly what Allah says he'll send us to
hell for, and you just did it. You just
you just told us to do exactly what
Allah says he'll send us to hell for."
Um, now you you you correctly point out
that in context, it's talking about
specific things that people are doing,
which I granted, but he doesn't just
say, "Hey, uh, you're you're you're
doing certain things and not doing other
things." He says, "Do you?" He switches
it to, "Do you only believe in parts of
the Torah and not in other parts? Cuz if
you do that, if you do what? If you only
believe in parts of the Torah and not in
all of it, he'll send you to hell." So
in context, yeah, he's he leads into
this discussion the examples of them
following certain parts and not
following other parts leads into, "Hey
guys, are you only are you only
believing in parts of your book? If you
because that's the problem here. You
only believe in parts of your book. if
you only believe in parts of your book,
I'm sending you to hell. And I pointed
out that's Allah speaking and every
almost every Muslim we meet says, "Yeah,
just believe in parts." Even though
Allah says that's what that's what he'll
send us to hell for. And I said,
"Muslims do that." And then the the
first thing you do is uh yeah, only
believe in parts because only parts are
true and parts are false. And we use the
Quran to decide. That's the problem.
You're using the Quran, but the Quran is
the book that tells us to to to believe
in all of it, not just parts. So how are
you using the Quran? You're saying, "Oh,
we judge. We're using the Quran to
decide. The book you're saying that you
use to decide the parts that we're
supposed to believe in specifically
orders us to believe in all of it. So if
you say not to believe in all of it,
you're not going with the Quran. You're
rejecting the Quran. You're an apostate.
You still there, little one? Maybe he
just showed up for parts of the stream,
not all of it. Oh, that was that was
that was a mic drop. Hi, guys. I've
never seen someone silent so long. Let
me just Yeah, there you go. Oh, okay.
Okay. Hello. Yeah, we're here. I'm
sorry. something happened. But I I heard
what you said, David. Uh and okay, you
made actually good points about the
uh accepting part of the toan rejecting
the risk. Okay, I will look into that.
Go ahead. That's it. That's all I got to
do. Okay. Uh uh are there any other
verses by the way? I'm just willing to
learn, but I'm not really trying to
debate or something. Hundreds. Hundreds
of verses. Yeah, we're not exaggerating.
There's actually hundreds of verses.
It's they all say
like or like confirming what is with
them, confirming what is with you. Like
all of these if you if you write the
word and do a search on Google on all
the verses in the Quran, there's lots of
them. Like 19 times it appears. Yeah.
Like so many times. and across lots of
suras like you know the big big suras in
the big in beginning of and even at the
you know some in the middle like surah
15 all of these verses
say confirming confirming what is with
you nowhere does it say some but not
others you will not find one verse in
the Quran that says some is goods and
not others in your book never but the
but in the mosque in the masjid and the
da people they say no some of it is
corrupted why because they realize the
problem now that is modern times people
are reading the books they realize that
the Quran is contradicting it so they
say well it must have been changed but
the Quran actually a Quran actually
never says that so it's a new it's a new
idea that the books our the books of
Allah are corrupted it's a new idea it's
not in the original Islam okay all right
okay Yeah. Nice one. Hello. Yeah. Yeah.
We're still here. You ready to leave
Islam, bro? Uh, yes. I listening to you.
I'm sorry. There's something wrong with
my phone. It's okay. It's all right. You
ready to leave Islam? What? Are you
ready to leave Islam? I will never leave
Islam. It's not Why not? Something
like you're saying the opposite of what
Allah says, but at least you said you
wanted to look into it. So, that's good.
No, because I because I am uh kind of
ignorant about it. So, I will do my
research. So if you do your research and
you find if you do your research, bro,
and you find that this actually is an
actual dilemma, you would stay in Islam
still?
Uh an actual to be honest, I don't know.
Even if I Yes, because I have other
evidence that the Islam is truly from
God and the Quran is truly from God.
What's what's the evidence? Sorry,
what's sorry, what's the evidence? That
would be another argument. Oh, what is
it? Give me one. Give me one. Cuz I hate
it when Muslims say that. Sorry. No, no
offense to you, little one. No, it's
not. No, no, no problem. Muslims Muslims
say, "I have two million reasons Islam
is true." And I asked them and they
can't even get me one. Okay. I just one
before you go. Just one so I can go
think about it before I sleep. Only one?
Only one? Okay. So,
in room Uhhuh. Oh, yeah. Okay. Okay.
Yeah. Go on. Verse number three is okay.
Yeah, I know all about the room. That
one? Yeah, you know it. I of course I
know it. I know it inside out. So tell
me how how does this make Islam true?
Okay. The Quran itself. Yeah. How does
it how does the room make Islam true?
Okay. So the verse says
Okay. Mhm. Uh, the battle between the
Romes and the Persians was actually
nailed to the to the region of the Dead
Sea. Can you hear me? Where do you see
the Persians there by the way? Where do
you see? Yeah. Yeah. Where do you see
the Persians? Where is the word
Persians? Hello. Can you hear me? Yes.
Yes. Yeah. Where where does it say the
word Persians? Because you said by the
Quran. So where does it say the word
Persians? Where is Persians? What is the
question? Where is the word Persian?
following the context. Actually, the was
about the battle between the Okay. What
is It doesn't say it. It doesn't say
that. It doesn't say that. Okay. It
doesn't say Persian. Okay. What is No,
it's a it's a it's a whole historical
context.
So, the verse the verse never says.
Okay. But the you acknowledge the verse
never says Persians, right? The the the
reason why you think Islam is true is
because of this battle between the
Romans and the Persians. And this verse
never mentions the word Persians, right?
We're with you so far. Self good. Yeah.
Yes. It just mentions Rome. No Persians.
So it could be any battle. Anyway, I
think his connection is too bad for
this. Okay. But just for those of you
guys who don't know there, what we're
talking about is uh what is sort of the
Rome uh which chapter 30. Okay. Verses
like 3 to four, right? 2 3 to four.
Yeah. uh when it talks about the Romans
conquering there's actually a variant
reading there which says that the Romans
were conquered. So you literally have
two
readings says that they conquered and
the other one says they conquer. So you
have it both ways. So you can pick the
battle and you can pick like what did
they do? They win or lose. And there's
more prompts that as well like there's a
Yeah. Hey Avery, can you put a hadith up
on the screen? I just I just sent it in
the uh private chat. Yeah. Is it is it
the one that says that the first fruit
is brewed after? I still don't know how
this how this right. Yeah, we hear you.
Yeah, we're going to we're going to read
a little hadith cuz uh think about what
So you said, you know, uh even if
there's an Islamic dilemma, you've got
so much uh evidence for Islam and DOC
asked you for one example. She asked you
she asked you for one example and the
one example you gave was this passage.
So for everyone who's not familiar uh
with this, the claim is that the claim
is that um Muhammad predicted that after
the Romans had been defeated, uh the
Romans would eventually be victorious
and win a battle over the Persians,
which you know, shocking, right? Oh no,
the ro the Romans the Romans will will
win a battle. No, hang on. Hang on. Let
me just let me just point out the the
the problem that hang on hang on just
let me read a hadith. These are the
words are these are uh these are this is
the historical background here. You
wanted the historical background. Jam
attorney 3192
um narrated at Abu narrated on the day
of Badr the Romans had a victory over
the Persians. So this is when the Romans
had the victory over the Persians after
you know the Persians had earlier uh
defeated the Romans. So on the day of
butter the Romans had a victory over the
Persians. So the believers were pleased
with that. Then the following was
revealed. Alf lim the Romans have been
defeated up to his saying the believers
will rejoice with the help of Allah. He
said so the believers were happy with
the victory of the Romans over the
Persians. So for anyone who's not
familiar with this this can be hard to
understand. The claim the Muslim the
general Muslim claim I don't know what
our friend here is going to argue but
the general Muslim claim is that how
could how could Muhammad have known that
the Romans will win a battle? And here
we have Hadith saying that this was re
it was revealed after the Romans won the
battle. In other words, this would be
like me saying now, hey, Trump's going
to win the 2024 election. Oh my
goodness, he did win the 2024 election.
It's a it's it's a miraculously
fulfilled prophecy by me. This says that
the verse was revealed after it already
happened. So, how can it be a prophecy
of something that's going to happen when
according to this, it was revealed after
the thing happened? So, anyway, but you
say you got a different point you wanted
to make. Go ahead. Yeah, that's not my
point. You really I didn't get what
you're saying, but kind of get of it
that that verse was revealing was
revealed after the victory. But no,
that's not really my point. Okay. What
really is how does this prove Islam is
correct? That's what I want to know.
It's not a proof. It's just a That's
what you said. That's what you said. I
said, "Give me one evidence." I said,
"Give me one evidence." Is now it's just
interesting. Now it's just interesting.
Yeah, it's interesting. It's It's
interesting. The Quran reports on a
battle that happened. Yeah. Yeah, I just
watched the news about a battle that
took place. What? Really? You have to
accept the news as a prophet now. Oh,
man. I didn't I didn't ask what is
interesting. I said, "What's your many
evidences Islam is true?" Many. Okay.
Yeah. This this was your number one that
you went to. This was your go-to your
go-to argument and it's something that
you find interesting that Muhammad
noticed Muhammad heard about a battle
that had taken place and he said, "Hey,
you guys are still interested cuz we got
other people." No, that's enough. It's
just to just wanted to prove a point
that when Muslims say, "No, I will never
leave because I have so much evidence,"
it just ends up being interesting and
not really any evidence at all. Yeah.
Because in Yeah. Because in reality,
you've simply heard all your life that
there's all this evidence and we hear
that too from Muslims, but then we say,
"Okay, what is the evidence?" And then
what what just happened is what happens
every time. Okay. Can I address my
point? Maybe next time. Yeah. You lost
your point now. You had one chance and
you lost it. You only get one shot. Do
not miss your chance to blow. David
Wood, David Wood put something in my
mouth say that I'm making another point,
but that's not really my point. You
start talking about the process. Yeah.
Yeah. Then then we gave you time to
explain your point. You just said, "I
don't know. Just find You didn't give me
time. You you you really took Okay. So,
bro. All right. Look, look. So, what is
it about chapter
30:4 that proves the Quran to be from
God?" Okay.
The has many meanings, but one of the
meaning is lowest. So it's in the lowest
land of the earth. And the battle that
happened uh with the Romans and the
Persians was in the region of the Dead
Sea which is now discovered in the 19th
centur 19th century that it is the
lowest point of earth. Okay. What's the
name? Okay. What's the name of that
battle? The name of that battle? Yeah.
So so that I can go search battles of
around the Dead Sea to to make sure it
is the lowest earth. What's the name of
the battle? I don't really remember the
name of that battle. Oh, come on, man.
You don't It doesn't exist. I'm telling
you, the name of that battle doesn't
exist in the whole of Islam. So, I can't
go check. No, it does exist. It doesn't.
Okay. What's the name? What's the name?
Okay, let me let me look or you can
look. Okay, go go go look it and come
back because people are waiting, I
think, forever. Okay, so remember my
point. Yeah, but your point doesn't make
any sense because I can't I can't search
it. We'll remember it, little one. I
can't check it. The disappear.